[Musique]
bonjour serge letchimy bonjour bonjour à
toute la martinique président du parti
progressiste martiniquais merci d'être
avec nous d'abord un mot du temps serge
letchimy un mode irma qui est en
approche notre population a redouté que
le que le phénomène nous concerne plus
directement elle a prié maintenant nous
pensons à nos amis des îles du nord qui
subiront pluie vent mari ou l'excès
terrain serge chimie vous êtes également
député l'action publique de prévention
de sensibilisation d'éducation est elle
suffisante pour faire face à ce genre de
phénomène l'action politique est elle
suffisante
non parce que il y a à la fois toute
l'organisation à mettre en oeuvre à la
france pour informer ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui relativement bien ou même
bien il ya aussi tout le travail tout le
travail qui a faire sur la question de
la sécurité civile se fait assez
correctement c'est à dire au moment où
le cyclone la tempête passe et après on
fait une prise en charge mais est tout
le problème c'est l'anticipation c'est
la prévention et nos élus les élus qui
sont en place en martinique y sont
sensibilisés à ce genre de choses a su
que je suppose je le pense sincèrement
nous sommes tous martiniquais
sensibiliser à ça lorsque j'étais à la
région on a distribué des kits ce coup
de survie à beaucoup de personnes ne pas
commune par quartier parce que pour moi
c'est la progression qui est la chose la
plus importante quand vous avez un
phénomène avec des vents de 200 km peur
c'est pas le cas pour irma ou un
tremblement de terre il faut absolument
que la prévention permettent que de se
préparer et je pense qu'il ya aussi un
travail à faire que assez considérable à
l'intérieur et à l'extérieur d'une
maison à consolider son nez maison pour
les tremblements de terre je pense à
marie luce qui fait un travail
considérable sur les meubles de survie
appelons ça comme ça rapidement
il faut poursuivre que la prise de
conscience soit réel en permanence les
sénatoriales
serge chimie neuf candidats clairment
annonçant un en attend peut-être deux de
plus avec le camp du grand ensemble et
c'est à confirmer plus de 10 ce serait
trop où une telle élection
je peux pas me permettre de dire ce
genre de choses que ce serait trop c'est
sûr
beaucoup de personnes c'est aussi un
état de santé assez bon état de santé de
la démocratie que les choix exprimés à
même la question de la discipline au
sein des phoques nous sommes dans ce
pays libre où les personnes s'est
exprimée veulent aller aux élections il
représente le peuple je trouve ça très
sain cette discipline par exemple lors
de la candidature à la candidature au
sein même du ppm une kyrielle de transit
des qui a pris ne joue plus franchement
le jeu est ce que est ce que ça ne jette
pas un peu ça ne sommes pas un peu le
trouble auprès dé la population qui
regarde tout ça avec le beaucoup de
distance
ouais c'est ça c'est ça m'attriste si
personnellement nous connaissez ce matin
qui vont pas quitter un mauvais rôle
dans la faire écouter on va faire le
procès dit vente
le débat est clos pour nous oui il y a
eu une candidate qui a été retenue par
le parti maurice martinet cas c'est
catherine conconne eelv ont manifesté et
protesté écrit nous avons tenu compte de
son équipe et on a pendant un mois je
suis même pas parti en vacances pour sa
part un mois auditionné chaque fois 5 3
heures de lys ion et il n'y a aucun
doute il n'y a pas eu de fraude est
absolument rien eu de ce fait on a
confirmé la candidature de madame
conconne donc on a le pnm à deux
candidats maurice antiste et catherine
conconne et puis à la marge il y a donc
ils vont pas quitte il y à tana jeanne
rose il y à un maurice bonté ce sont des
gens qui sont très très proches de la
coalition ensemble pour une martinique
nouvelle le pmn n'a pas quelque part mis
en marche la machine à perdre
ça peut s'interpréter comme ça si on
considère qu' il y a
d'autres enjeux qui sont personnelle
individuelle en ce concerne le parti
progressiste martiniquais nous allons
laver notre linge sale en famille
cependant c'est assez légitime que
d'autres personnes présentes
l'organisation je pense labonté pour
monsieur atteindre 11 c'est un petit peu
plus compliqué puisqu'il est à la fois
de deux mouvements nous allons clarifier
ça tantôt avant de poursuivre notre
notre entreprise une dernière question
est-ce que vous avez peser
personnellement serge letchimy est ce
que vous avez peser personnellement pour
que jenny dulys retire sa candidature
dimensionnement pas je ne pèse pas du
tout ce genre de décisions savez nous
votons à bulletins secrets à la fois le
pnm ce qui a été fait et au parti
progressiste martiniquais donc on vote
en âme et conscience c'est d'ailleurs
pour cela que c'est un mouvement le
parti progressiste martiniquais un parti
qui tient depuis plus de 50 ans et
deuxièmement c'est un parti très
démocratique et deuxièmement le pnm nous
avons à peu près la même méthode
on vote à bulletin secret et gêné lui
c'est quelqu'un d'exceptionnel de
remarquables elle a fait une analyse l'a
arrêté sa décision
son mouvement je respecte et là mon
admiration alors c'est rejeter mais on a
quand même la pression c'est du ppm que
ces derniers temps la maison de traînel
était devenu une sorte de maison pour
tous mpt cabinet mon cas pas si mon café
au lait on a parlé d'yvon paquita
l'instant il y en a eu d'autres
et il ferait de lordinot daniel sommer
rico plainte et puis même daniel robin
on n'a pas l'impression qu'il faut
peut-être rappeler les règles de
fonctionnement des tirs à l'intérieur du
parti pris il faut rappeler les règles
même pas de manière dictatoriale pas de
manière violente on vous reproche à vous
d'être directeur des contradictions non
vous l'avez entendu sa part de vos deux
capteurs non nous avons on entend tout
et ouais mais vous savez je veux pas
devenir violent je pense qu'il faut
laisser s'exprimer et des individus il y
à des volontés qui sont saines il ya des
volontés malsaine aussi dans une famille
dans votre famille vous avez des gens
bien des gens m'ont bien et maintenant
il faut écouter
il faut faire appliquer les procédures
c'est nous nous savons faire appliquer
les procédures dans chaque cas que vous
avez cités on prendra le temps il ya un
bureau politique
un comité national et on ira jusqu'au
bout quand il le faut parce qu'il s'agit
de séduire l'électorat de convaincre les
martiniquais mais qui aura deux
prochaines échéances et que vous serez
de la partie on peut parler de municipal
de 2020 il y aura également l'assemblée
de martine 2021 alors sur quelle base
sur une redéfinition du progressisme
puisque tout le monde en parle
aujourd'hui tout nombre de 6 tonnes doit
commencer j'ai dit c'est très bien de le
dire tout comme un progressiste
ça construit bien ça montre bien que ces
erreurs avaient parfaitement anticipé
d'offrir aux décisions se prennent à
définir le progressisme le progressisme
est très claire dans nos têtes au parti
progressiste martiniquais
j'ai entendu parler du progressisme
macron si le progressisme annoncé
supprimer des abbés et une part des apl
et 5 euros
si c'est ça mais le progressisme acron
c'est de remettre en cause des emplois
aidés et si le progressisme a construit
comment travailler sur la compétitivité
en recherche une flexibilité au
détriment principalement du travailleur
bien sûr je considère que la révision du
code du travail c'est quelque chose qui
peut être utile et non c'est pas mon
prouvé ici ne s'est pas improvisé
technologique le progressisme du parti
pourrissement heynckes est d'abord un
droit d'initiative locale c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que je n'ai pas
adhéré au mouvement mâcon local fo lire
la lettre à maurice thorez c'est le
droit d'initiative locale
c'est l'émancipation de l'homme c'est
très important et ensuite notre propre
émancipation collective en faisant
respecter à la fois notre identité nos
dignité de martiniquais guadeloupéens de
réunionnais et ça je ne trouve pas ça
ailleurs que dans le parti progressiste
martiniquais avec des pouvoirs et des
responsabilités assumées localement dans
une république qui s'appelle la
république française et dans le cadre de
leroy c'est à la fois conjuguer le droit
à l'égalité c'est à dire les droits que
nous avons aujourd'hui des droits
sociaux edouard justice etc pour qu'on
n'est pas ce que nous avons aujourd'hui
toutes formes de manipulation à la fois
du peuple de la justice que je vois et
puis poindre dans l'organisation
des responsables actuels c'est quelque
chose de très très violent de très dur
et je le dis en passant s'il y a quelque
chose qui est parfaitement réussit pas
et la ctm l'actuel président la ctm
c'est qu'il a réussi à installer la
terreur et on est alors que ses devants
aux siens en les programmant sur moment
il a réussi à installer la terre et en
installer la terreur on peut assurément
être très violent avec des salariés de
la ctm la sphère du parc naturel
régional et est extrêmement incroyable
ce qui s'est passé que la drh du comité
martiniquais du tourisme compte pire
et avec cela nous allons très négatif
sur ce qui se passe en partie c'est
aujourd'hui oui absolument et c'est un
c'est une posture une attitude qui qui
fait chuter moralement un pays et qui
met en difficulté d'autant plus quand il
n'y a pas d'investissement
il n'y a pas de travail du tout
numérique est un mâle selon vous ces
rejets mais c'est pas un jeu il suffit
de lire contacter l'entreprise il suivit
le lier à lier d'hommes de l'insee vous
avez la situation en matière de ventes
de ciment cette année dit un indicateur
on est actuellement au niveau le plus
bas depuis 37 ans c'est pas la chimie le
dit ces contacts ont tant pis ce qu'il
écrit noir sur blanc
le chômage est en train d'augmenter le
climat des affaires a chuté de trois
points donc on a une situation assez
catastrophique en plus comme au niveau
national au niveau européen on serre les
boulons
ce c'est clair mais l'exemple du
contraire dsk caire eh bien si
localement on se prend par m 3e série
phedra on aura de graves divisions
vendus et puis on voit par exemple tcsp
quitte à l'arrêt qui aurait pu être un
symbole d'une martinique qui avance sur
ce dossier n'en va pas revenir sur la
polémique c'est pas moi c'est l'autre
c'est l'autre c'est pas moi etc
mais est-ce qu en amont dans la
préparation dans la veine de l'avènement
de 7,2 ce tcsp
est ce qu'à votre niveau vous êtes pas
dit qu'il y aurait peut-être des choses
qu'il aurait fallu faire autrement
pour éviter cette situation de sur place
de stagnation voire de régression
moi je très fier de ce que notre cas qui
paraît ali
et pendant les cinq ans on a réalisé en
trois ans et demi ce qu'on n'a pas fait
en 25 ans donc le tcsp là il suffit de
faire rouler deux organiser des choses
n'est une volonté très claire ou pas
vous êtes journaliste il ya une volonté
extrêmement claire de ne pas faire
fonctionner tcsp en continu a menti au
peuple on avait dit que ça allait
commencer airs prononciation grimal en
bas ça profite à ceux qui décident de ne
pas faire fonctionner le tcsp parce que
si on fait fonctionner le tcs ucd chimie
qui reggae s'est dit chimiques et
profiter de la modernisation transports
c'est un raisonnement dingue fou est
totalement personnalisés oui je le dis
clairement parce que ce n'est pas
possible de tricher de mentir comme ça
la population vous savez lorsque j'ai
organisé j'étais président de la cacem à
l'époque le transport mosaïque
il y avait cent trente-sept transporter
à schoelcher saint-joseph lamentin
frolov ans il nous a fallu deux ans et
demi à trois années pour voir
coordonnées 637 transporteurs pour avoir
un seul des transporteurs mosaïque mais
a fallu trois ans donc si on commence à
un négociant qui transporte aujourd'hui
qu'ils vont pas arriver apprennent simon
moi qui veux rester à ducos du cos mais
la situation risque d'être
catastrophique n'est pas parti pour le
tcsp dans six mois dans un an c'est dans
deux trois ans donc il faut être clair
on est en train d'abîmer les plus
démunis les plus faibles parce que le
transport est utilisée par les plus
faibles les plus pauvres
et c'est cela bien crime contre ces
personnes de bloquer de ces espèces
merci d'avoir été ce matin avec
nostalgie me rappelle vous êtes le
président du parti progressiste
martiniquais est également député de la
martinique merci bonne journée
[Musique]
et greta